the boys are back in town well almost
when can you watch season three who's
going to be in it what exactly is
stumpfront check it all outs and so much
more right here
amazon prime announced the release date
of season 3 via a fictional news
broadcast from vort news networks 7 on 7
with cameron coleman the vote
international is a shady multi-billion
dollar conglomerate that oversees the 7.
the online short includes a contentious
and brief interview between coleman and
huey now a senior analyst for the
federal bureau of superhuman affairs the
search is also one for two new members
to join the seven via a reality series
hosted by starlight the faux newscast
concludes with a close-up of homelander
who appears to be holding his public
persona together with a very thin thread
before revealing the season's june 3rd
debut date
deadline also reported that season 3 of
the boys will return with a three
episode premiere on friday june 3rd new
episodes will air every subsequent
friday and wrap up on july 8th with that
in mind it looks like it's going to be
an exciting summer
the teaser trailer for the boys season 3
offered up plenty of glimpses of the
action to come without giving much of
the story away the trailer shows
starlight and homelander in the midst of
a promo shoot and it's obvious that
homelander has yet to recover from the
events of season 2. we see billy butcher
getting his first taste of super powers
we get a glimpse of what looks like the
in-world reality show american hero and
most importantly we get a few shots of
jensen ackles a soldier boy in action
mostly the teaser gives a vibe of
tension and mayhem which is pretty much
on brand for the boys but look closer
and there are actually a ton of clues of
what's to come in the season
according to deadline the main cast is
definitely returning for season three
homelander billy butcher huey and all
the rest of them will be back for even
more mayhem and yes it looks like black
noir wakes up from his candy induced
coma
is that an almond joy
he has a tree nut allergy
a quick shot in the trailer confirms our
ford ceo stan edgar will return as well
but there are also some incredible
newcomers to the cast this season the
most exciting new addition is
supernatural star jensen eccles a
soldier boy the original homelander the
new players don't end there however in
june 2021 a deadline reported that the
boys had added three new cast members in
recurring roles sean patrick flannery
portrays gunpowder miles gaston via
nueva is super sonic and nick wexler
will play yet another new soup named
blue hawk deadline has also confirmed
that frances turner kristen booth and
jack doolin are joining the series yet
another super division is lori holden as
crimson countess a parody of marvel
scarlet witch in shorts there will be
plenty of new faces in season 3 and it
will definitely be intriguing to see
this many supes on one screen
the boys were cleared of all charges and
came out of hiding at the end of season
two with huey taking a job under
victorian newman a congresswoman who's
against divorce yet is also a
head-exploding super self this likely
means that huey will distance himself
from the boys it's clear he's joining
the wrong team as newman isn't the
picture-perfect person he believes her
to be it appears as though huey is in
grave danger and it's not out of the
question that his former associates will
try to save him at some point
showrunner eric kripke has hinted that
things will go south for huey during the
upcoming third season he told tv guide
the thing about huey is that he's not
particularly good at the ultra violence
but he's very competent and i think we
wanted to show that off via newman he's
very smart he's a good investigator he's
amazing with technology he has great
ideas but of course it's all going to go
to hit on him the boys might be
separated at first but it's presumably
only a matter of time before the titular
group teams up once again
if you've been wondering how the
upcoming third season of the boys will
kick off eric kripke has dropped a major
hint revealing the title of the first
episode payback well this could be a
reference to the event of the previous
season payback is actually the name of a
super team one that was around before
the seven in an interview with the
illuminati kripke was asked which new
characters fans should look forward to
seeing he said all of them i mean i
think that you'll get amazing things to
do season three is fun because it's not
just about soulja boy but it's about the
team he was a part of which is called
payback to dig into the history of the
world not just the present has been a
lot of fun i i don't know what they're
gonna do with soldier boy because
soldier boy in the comics at least was
an older soup i believe he was the first
soup bot ever injected with compound v
we'll have to wait and see what goes
down in the season three opener but the
fact that the title of the episode and
the name of soldier boys team are both
payback it's telling
fans of the boys have been wondering at
the tv show with dare touch the infamous
hero gasm miniseries ever since amazon
announced that the comic was getting an
adaptation we now know that it will and
it will go down during the sixth episode
of season three kryptke teased how crazy
the hero gasm episode will be telling
entertainment weekly herogasm the
dailies are bananas i've been around the
block a few times i'm a seasoned
producer every single day on those
dailies my jaw was on the floor i just
could not believe how insane those
dailies were for those not in the know
the hero gaza miniseries is about an
annual party held by supes under the
guise of combating an alien threat they
get together on a remote island for a
weekend of shameless debauchery
i'll do it for you
for america
although stormfront offered appeared
invincible in season two the fascist
soup met a match when she came face to
face with homelander son ryan who
displayed his powerful eye lasers for
the first time the result was the
accidental death of becker and
stormfront losing her limbs if
stormfront hadn't been juiced up on
compound v she probably wouldn't have
survived the encounter but according to
showrunner eric kripke she's still
clinging to life somewhere he told the
rap she's not dead she's stumpf front
now
you know no comment about whether she
comes back but she is forever going to
be this kind of mutilated stubby little
nazi which we thought was a right
punishment for somebody who so believed
in iron purity
i did not see that coming from you
according to ayakash the actor who
brought the vile soup to life stormfront
won't be involved in season three
telling metacritic i'll be watching with
the rest of you guys unfortunately
so unfair
given everything the seven has been
through not to mention the corruption
that tends to surround them it would be
a minor miracle for them to get back on
the same page let alone the same team
they will no doubt continue to act like
buddies while the cameras are rolling
but it's just a charade as we know the 7
is held together by marketing alone at
this point and of course the deep was
still to be reunited with his fellow
supes at the end of season 2. however
with the payback team said to take
center stage perhaps a 7 will at least
come together to achieve a common goal
homelander promised to leave starlight
butcher and ryan alone at the end of
season two the seven and four pin
everything on stormfront and most of the
seven go back to being superheroes at
the end of season two it seems as though
it will be business as usual at least
for a little while
it's already been well established that
homelander has little to no regard for
human life he does however thrive on the
love of the public if someone comes in
and takes his top spot that someone
could meet their demise and soulja boy
may find himself in homelanders
crosshairs soulja boy may be better at
charming the people but he's not as
powerful as homelander and then there's
congresswoman newman her supercharged
suit powers and tendency to explode
important people's heads are still
unknown to the characters despite being
revealed to the audience needless to say
there are plenty of threats entering
season 3 and it remains to be seen who
will clash let alone who will live or
die though we don't exactly know how
events will unfold it's already been
announced that soldier boy isn't going
to be a nice guy kripke told variety i
think anyone expecting jensen to show up
and be a good guy they will be
disappointed he's one of these guys
that's been around for decades of vought
history and he was homelander before
homelander so he's from a different era
but he's got the ego and the ambition it
just comes across in a different way
because he's from a different time
when it comes to violence the voice
isn't for the faint-hearted is that a
human hand
yes it is come on we gotta go did anyone
expect the third chapter to be any
different in a chat with collider actor
laz alonso made it clear that season 3
is going to be a total bloodbath saying
i was talking to the head makeup artist
and she's in charge of ordering the
blood that's one of her many jobs she
told me that's all of season 2 when you
talk about bulk i don't think they used
over a gallon of blood in season 2
believe it or not season 3 we're already
at 3 and a half gallons of blood
so that should give you a little
indication of where it's going given how
season 2 ended season 3 should be pretty
wild especially since there's going to
be more soups than ever if there's one
thing we know about soups is that they
can be unpredictable cruel and lethal
they can blow things up including people
at any given moment the more soups there
are the more messy events will be
in the comics huey takes compound v in
order to level the playing field giving
him super strength a tv show appears to
be giving that storyline to butcher as
teaser trailers have shown him shooting
lasers from his eyes butcher lost the
love of his life not long after
discovering that she was still alive and
given birth to homelanders child he's
going to be gunning for homelander like
never before in season 3 and the fact
that he now has some of the same or at
least very similar powers makes her
inevitable showdown or the more exciting
it's honestly getting hard to hold all
this excitement in
speaking of homelander teaser trailers
have also shown that he's still got a
thing about milk and is apparently now
going straight to the source we know
that things are going to get tense as
soulja boy and the payback team enter
the picture but little snippets like
this have shown that season 3 will still
include the dark humor the show is known
for another example is a trains energy
drink music video which appears to be a
direct parody of kendall jenner's
much-maligned pepsi ad the boys knows
how to shock us but it never fails to
make us laugh either in the end there's
probably only one way to describe the
boys season three
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]